لم تكن بدايه المونديال موفقه لليونيل
ميسي وطبعا السبب السعوديه
وللمفارقه السعوديون يحبون ميسي من حيث
المبدا وهو بطل الحمله اعلانيه ضخمه عن
بلادهم ورغم خيبه ميسي امام الخضري لانه
سجل هدفا لكنه تحت ضغط كبير لتحقيق الكاس
في اخر مونديال يشارك فيه لان القاعده غير
المعلنه في كره القدم دون كاس لن تكون
مارادونا ولكن مسيره ميسي مع المنتخب
لديها نقطه ضوء وحيده الفوز بكوبا امريكا
يطمح للجائزه الكبرى هذه السنه المراقبون
يؤكدونا ميسي استعاد كثيره من بريقه وشغفه
في النصف الاول من الموسم مع فريقه باريس
سان جيرمان المنتخب
ميسي الذي لا ترحمه الصحافه للارجنتينيه
وتصب بطاطات الاوضاع الاقتصاديه في البلاد
على اكتافه عليه ان يقاتل وهو شخصيه
الاسبوع في صباح
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قبل المونديال قلميسي انه يشعر بالقلق وشد
الاعصاب لانها اخر كاس عالم
تخفيف الحمل على نفسه المونديال الاخير
كالجبل على اكتاف ميسي
الاخيره ومشجع كره القدم يشعرون ان اللعبه
ندينا لهذا الرجل
مع فريقه لنهائي كوبا امريكا في 2015
و2016 لكنه خسرهما في المناسبتين
انهار ميسي بالبكاء على ارضيه الملعب ولم
يحتمل الضغط امام عينه اصبحت الصوره واضحه
لن اكون مارادونا جديد لهذا الشعب واخيرا
قرر الاعتزال الدولي بعد مساهمته في
الخساره واضاعته ركنه ترجع
بعد اقل من شهرين تراجع ميسي عن القرار
بعد اتصال هاتفيه من رئيس الارجنتين وقتها
موريسيو ماكري والملايين في بلاد الشمس
وفي خارجها وقال في بيان حبي لوطني وهذا
القميص عظيم جدا سنوات اخرى من الاخفاقات
والجمهور لا يرحم حتى جاءت اللحظه
المنتظره انطلقت صافره نهائي كوبا امريكا
2021 لتعلن فوز الارجنتين وفي لقطه عاطفيه
يجثوا ميسي على ركبته ويدرف دموع اول
بطوله يحققها مع البلاد بعد 15 عاما من
تمثيله القميص الابيض والازرق الثانوي
مونديال 20 22 لميسي والمعنويات عاليه
وبعد 36 فوزا خسرت الارجنتين امام
السعوديه في مفاجاه تاريخيه فهل ينهي
الاخفاق امال ميسي
على كل حال من الاردن سالنا عدد من مشجعي
كره القدم ومشجعين ميسي بالاخص اكثر
هل يجب الضغط على ليونيل ميسي للفوز بكاس
العالم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
لست من من يسددون الكره فيخطئون الهدف هذا
ما عرف به لاعب كره القدم ميسي وبعض تعليق
الامال عليه حمله معجب خساره الفريق
باكمله
[موسيقى]
يعني بطلب منه شد حيله بس انه الحمد لله
العرب كمان انه فاز امبارح ورفعوا راسنا
انا بحكي لميسي انه هاي مباراه كره قدم
يعني فيها الربحان وفي الخصاب بالعكس كان
ايذاءه كثير رائعه كثير بس الحظ ما كان
معه ميسي هي الكل الدنيا بدهم برتقال طبعا
هنشوفها مع النهائي يعني حتى وانا بشجع
المانيا حاب اشوفها الفريقين لانه خلص
يعني اللجنس تاعون الكره
والزمن كل اللي حواليه بس
ضرب الشوط الثاني ما عرفش يلعب بالسعوديه
لعبه كثير كويس الحارس والمدافعين لعبوا
كويس
جدا
[موسيقى]
العالمي الرياضي وحيد المصري وحيد نورتنا
صباح الخير مع نفسك بالعربيه
ميسي منتخب التانجو النجم الارجنتيني
صانعه التاريخ في الاهداف هل يمكن ان نقول
انه فقط
يعيش في ظل ربما صاحب هذا ظل ليس طويل
القامه لكن في كره القدم طويل جدا
مارادونا يجب ان يخرج من هذا الظل وهذه
الفرصه الاخيره له ليخرج من هذا الظل
للاسف في البدايه لم تكن جيده الخساره
امام السعوديه القت بالمزيد من الشكوك كما
قال ميسي بعد المباراه في منطقه المقابلات
مع الاعلاميين كنا امواتا في المباراه
الان يحتاج ميسي الى معجزه جديده ان يعيد
الارجنتين من الاموات مباراتين 180 دقيقه
حتى يحتفظ باعماله وامال الملايين منه
مشجعي الارجنتين للبقاء في المونديال
التاهل للدور الثاني الامن
توقف عن التفكير في المونديال باللقب لان
التفكير الى عدم الخروج المخجل من الدور
الاول
هناك كنت انت ضيف في النشره الاخباريه
بمعنى اليوم وهذا بالتالي يعني اليوم انا
حسيت استشفيت من كلامك انه ميسي لم يصبح
ولم يخلد اسطوره كمارانه
ميسي يعيش همم تناقض يعني هو صح من مواليد
الارجنتين طفولته عاش فيها لكن كثيرين من
بلاده يعتبروا بانه ابن برشلونه ذهب الى
كتالونيا في سن مبكر لاعب مع نادي برشلونه
افضل انجازاته قبل القطر في امريكا طبعا
كانت مع نادي برشلونه
النتيجه في مونديال القطر ستعزز هذه الجهه
او الجهه الاخرى
مع فريقه اليوم ميسي نراه يبدع في الانديه
ويلام دائما وينتقد بانه لا يلعب جيدا مع
فريقه في المونديال وفي بطولات كاس العالم
ما الذي يحصل تحديدا لميسي ميسي
ليست كره قدم حاليا في 2022 طريقه اللاعب
التكتيك المهام المطلوبه من اللاعبين
مختلفه تماما نوعيه اللاعبين تختلف يعني
ربما نلقي بارقام بوجه ميسي لكن كره القدم
ليست فقط ارقام النتيجه النهائيه ليست كل
شيء رغم ما يعتبره لبعض
اهو طيب وحيد لو كان ميسي يهتم الجسدي
وبالتركيز على جسده مثل ما يقوم به
كريستيانو رونالدو هل صمد اكثر وبقي اطول
في الملعب وفي طبعا يجب ان ننظر الى
المهام المطلوبه كلاعب لا يلعب بنفس
المركز رغم انه الجماهير تحب الاعلام
المقارنه بين اللاعبين لكن كل لاعب لهما
مختلفه هذا مهاجم صريح هذا يلعب اكثر في
خط الوسط يصنع الالعاب يعني المقارنه لا
تبدو منطقيه بوجهه محلليه كره قدم في
التفاصيل لكن الاعلام يحب دائما البطل
ونقيده يحب همم يجب ان تكون لتكون بطلا
يجب ان يجد لك الشرير الخاص بك لتفوز عليه
وتتفوق وترفع الرايه يعني هذه مساله
اعلاميه ودعائيه
غير موفقه تماما في المونديال مونديال قطر
هذا العام هل سيتدا ذلك
مباراتين الان يعني ربما اذا نظرنا الى
الاداء اللي قدم منتخب الارجنتين رغم انه
لم يسجل الا هدف واحد من ضربه جزاء يعني
لم يسجل من اللاعب المفتوح لكنه صنع فرص
عديده قدم لمسات ربما اكثر من 29 او 30
لمسه للكره داخل منطقه الجزاء الفريق نفسه
والسعوديه يعني يوجد بذور للنجاح الان
امام منتخب بولندا اولا بس هو المنتخب
المكسيك ربما يحتاج الى فوزيه ربما يكفيه
فوز وتعادل بناء على باقي النتائج تعادل
بولندا مع المكسيك في الجوله الاولى اعطى
امل اكثر للارجنتينيين طيب
مراق كون انه كثرت احبطات ميسي خصوصا بعد
طرده من برشلونه وانتقاله الى همم الى
باريس اليوم كونها اخر كاس عالم لميسي هل
يعني حتما بانه شعبيته تتراجع او انه يعني
هو لن يبذل هذا المجهود الكبير
يعني
الطموح الطموح الشخصي هو الدافع الاول
طموح الذاتي بالنسبه لاي شخص اخر حقك كل
هذا البطولات مع الانديه الكوبا امريكا
ال- كاس الابطال على حساب ايطالي ايضا همم
يبقى الدافع الوحيد لديه هو شخصيا ماذا
تريد ان تكتب في سجلاتك تكتب اسمك بجانب
كاس العالم طبعا لا ننسى 2014 مر بجانب
الكاس كوصيف
الان فرصه الاخيره ليرفع اللقب يبقى يبقى
دائما الدافع الشخصي للنجاح اكبر من اي
دافع خارجي لكن اكيد سينام قرير العين حتى
لو ما فاز ببطوله العالم بالنسبه له يبقى
يعني بطلا الرضا النفسي داخل ربما اهم من
اي امور اخرى لكن يساعد انه وجود كاس عالم
بجانبك شكرا جزيلا نورتنا في الاستديو
وحيد المصري